e
[Silence]
for
albb
allahar
ASU
ill Ash
[Silence]
Ashu
mam
Ash
muham
[Silence]
Sal
f
[Silence]
allahar
ill
[Silence]
alhamdulillah
aldd
[Silence]
Al
subhah
waala
[Silence]
m
my dear brothers respected Elders
beloved youth mothers and sisters we
thank Allah subhana wa ta'ala
for keeping us alive one more day on the
path of Islam on the and keeping us
alive to see the beautiful month of
Ramadan we ask Allah subhana tala to let
us finish the Ramadan in the entirety
and may Allah accept from us all the
little things we have done is the
Ramadan a mean and I bear witness
there's no deity worthy of worship
except for Allah subhana wa ta'ala
for surely he Allah subhana tala choose
to guide n should can misguide him and
who are CH who Allah subh chooses to
misguide n shall guide him back back to
the path and we seek refuge in Allah
from darkness of ourselves and evil of
our Deeds for Allah is all knowing and
allseeing what his creation
does alhamdulillah we stand on the eve
of a beautiful day and a beautiful night
we ask Allah subhana tala to make one of
this this odd night to be one of the
nights of and I ask Allah subhana tala
that He blesses us to worship him in the
manner that he wants us to worship him
in the we ask Allah subh to accept it at
the face value that he has blessed with
a
mean as we started the month of Ramadan
before the month of Ramadan started I
had mentioned the Ayah has mentioned ay
number
183 I have prescribed Allah says I
prescribed fasts for you just as I
prescribed fast for people and donations
before you so you become mindful of
Allah subhana tala in this month I have
noticed a trend I've noticed that a lot
of folks that I've talked to even with
my own self there is this feeling that
we have that I have not done
enough or if I have done enough is it in
a proper manner what am I missing why am
I doing this way why am I not more
steadfast on the path of Allah subhana
wa taala why am I not more stronger in
my IM in My fasting why is that and
first and foremost if you have those
feelings
alhamd you have some IM and some tawa in
you
alhamdulillah the worrisome part is when
we go through month of Ramadan and we
are fasting and abstaining and we don't
have that mindfulness is this enough am
I doing enough to please my Lord have I
done so have I done any better this
month than I have done in previous years
in My fasting of Ramadan and that in a
nutshell is what tawa is it's
mindfulness of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
it's the same mindfulness when me and
you walk into grocery stores full of
food and delicious items and cold drinks
and beverages that we can pick up and
drink and nobody would know and yet we
stop ourselves from doing that that is
what tawa of Allah subhana tala
is that is the mindfulness and having
that emptiness and the feeling inside of
you have I done enough is the right way
to feel about it because the minute you
feel hey I have achieved and successed
and succeeded in it guess what that's
the
downfall that's when you become arrogant
and hotti and you have this thing about
you that you walk around and you start
looking at people and you say you I
see you once some day just for and you
leave I'm here in the Masid doing and I
stay after that too that's not the right
way to look at what we have achieved in
this beautiful
month the mindfulness is the key to our
success in every single Avenue that we
have this mindfulness is what we feel
that bothers Us in this month but why in
the month of Ramadan because it's a
blessed month the revelation of Allah
subhana was revealed in this
month Allah brought down the Quran in
the last 10
days the first revelation of last 10
days
toam and he reminded us with the first
verses of
Revelation
he reminds us read in your lord's name
who has created you from a little clot a
little blood clot that had no
value and then he talks in the he talks
about in the creation of man he says
Allah created you from a water that is
dirty that's our
beginning used to say I do not
understand how a man can be prideful and
boastful he was created from a dirty
water he ends up in the grave and
becomes the food of the animals and and
creatures in the earth and he carries
his waist all day long in his belly and
then he walks around he says I am this
and I am that this is the creation and
the real realization of a human being
and what we
are so this emptiness we have we need to
have that emptiness because it makes us
to strive further to Allah subhana wa
taala and it tries us to connect to
Allah subhana tala but let me not let me
stop at
this because there is something else on
the table from Allah subhana wa ta'ala
that we do not
realize when we commit a mistake if I do
a mistake if I go against one of you if
I verbally abuse one of you if I hit one
of you
and I say the wrong thing to you any one
of you and then I come back and say
brother please forgive me I have errored
I have sinned I made a mistake I wasn't
thinking properly at that time there is
a possibility that you might forgive
me but you will not
forget that's human
nature we're willing to forgive but we
don't forget
often
except for those people who Allah has
blessed with because forgiveness itself
is just not forgiving the act it is
erasing it in entirety from your books
altogether and when we think of
forgiveness of Allah subhah wa ta'ala we
equate it to forgiveness of human beings
which is not fair to Allah subhana wa
tala Allah's forgiveness is nothing like
the Forgiveness of a human being
a poet said you know he
[Silence]
said
oh Allah if only the pious can come to
you and ask for forgiveness where do we
Sinners Go Ya
Allah where do we go y I knew my sins
have become so great but then I found
out your forgiveness is greater than my
sins Ya Allah I ask you as you have told
me to ask you but if you return my hands
empty-handed where do I go Ya Allah
who do I go ask for forgiveness if you
return my hands empty what door do I go
back upon Ya
Allah who will forgive me except for you
created me Ya Allah where do I go what
door do I have to knock
on I have no other Avenue just yet to
return back to you every single
time and I know your forgiveness is
beautiful and know that I'm a humble
servant of you
Allah stop equating Allah's mercy and
rahma with people's mercy and rahma they
are not the same my forgiveness and your
forgiveness is not the same I remind you
entering Jenna is just not based on your
good deeds and bad
Deeds except for the mercy of Allah tala
in English we call it
Grace nobody will enter the paradise
except for the grace of Allah subhana
tala and his grace is much bigger than
anything me and you can imagine that
exists wasallam
said have mercy Allah forgives and has
Mercy on the people who give forgive
mercy so have Grace for people just like
you expect to have Grace from Allah
[Arabic recitation]
be forgiving be be
forgetful have mercy on those on the
earth and the one in the the heavens
will have mercy upon you this is a
simple prescription my brothers and my
sisters to follow if we need to come
close to Allah
subh this is one of the simplest
things Allah subh
say you see the expansions of the
heavens and the Earth today the
scientist tells you the the Galaxy are
expanding at a more rapid Pace than we
know and they're rapidly expanding every
day and this is only the one one Heaven
that we can
see what we can't see is seven more that
Allah has
created so all the creation all the
beauty that he has created he says my
Mercy is much wider and bigger than
that so on this blessed day on this
blessed Eve have the best best
intentions with Allah subhah wa ta'ala
seek his mercy and forgiveness while you
are being merciful and forgiving to
others it's a two-way street it cannot
be a one-way Street you have to put
something
in
said
oh the one your sinner do not become
despondent from mercy of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala for your lord is the most
forgiving do not have be despondent with
Allah subhana
tala often meet Brothers I don't know
brother if my Salah is accepted my soul
brother it's not your
worry Allah subhana said to make Salah
we make Salah he said to fast we do our
best in fasting Allah knows we're not
perfect and it isn't one
Perfection it's going to school at
any level you walk into your class for
final exam and they tell you before you
get to graduate this is the last exam
you have to take it's 100 points there's
10 questions on it each worth 10 point
but if you get one question right for
one point I'll give you all the points
to graduation
who would be not excited for that
exam I know I'll be excited yes one
question I get it what is that
question that's the that's the salvation
that's the grace Allah has given us do
not die except you are in the submission
of Allah subhana tala so let's let's not
forget his Mercy that is expanding and
covering every single thing in the
universe let's not compare our actions
with the actions of Allah subhana tala
let's not compare our Mercy or our
kindness to each other with the kindness
of human beings because there is no
comparison between us and Allah subhana
tala
while you're at it have the same
compassion and mercy and Grace for your
fellows none of us are perfect none us
of are
perfect let me finish with a story of a
young
man who comes to the
masi he sits
down and he's heard making this Dua to
Allah subhana
tala
oh the greatest forgive my greater
sins soam hears this young man praying
he prays one Sal
inam comes and calls him and he said so
are you are you you think you're
forgiven he says no he goes back and he
starts making the same Dua over and over
again waits for him he prays a second
Salah calls him and he says you feel
better he's no
says to him glad Tiding Allah subh has
forgiven everything you have
done just that moment we do not need
those fancy words and books to tell us
the story of the of the boy the young
man from bani is let me finish with this
inshallah this young man from bani is
who had done every single thing IM at
the time in his community so much so
imagine bani is themselves kicked him
out they said you cannot live amongst us
this is it you have crossed every single
boundary that there is to be crossed get
away from here he leaves the town and he
goes somewhere desolate to live all by
himself Allah subhana sends the angel to
musat he says yeah M if you want B
isel's sins forgiven and everybody
else's sins forgiven and you want to
have aeder for that go and pray the
janaza of this man who has died in that
is dying in that place
so M takes everybody in B is and they go
to a desolate place when they get their
amazement it's the same young man who
there taking his last breaths so the BN
is says mus what's wrong with you this
this sinner we came here to pray for his
janaza no so Musa asked Allah subhana
tala he says Ya Allah what's the matter
Allah says Musa he was a sinner he did
every single thing imaginable but in a
moment before sakarat hit him he asked
me sincerely and I forgave him not only
did I forgive him I made him a way of
forgiveness for
everybody do not do not look at your
fellow brother and think I am better
than him my sister I'm better than him
always think of yourself as the lowest
of the
lowest
I ask Allah subhana ta'ala to make today
the day of blessed day of Friday the way
of exit of our nexts from the Hellfire
and the next of our forefathers and our
mothers and our siblings and our family
members and our fathers and our
grandfathers and the whole of Muslim
umah anyone who has died on the Cal of
relieve their nexts on the
Hellfire Ya Allah we ask you to accept
from us we know we did not done good in
this this month there's a lot of things
wrong with us but we're still your
slaves Ya Allah take us as we
[Silence]
are
alhamdulillah
[Silence]
mentions in authentic narration that he
heard
say fear Allah subh or have mindfulness
of Allah subh T wherever you
are and follow your ill Deeds with
something good it will erase the effects
of the bad Deeds
my brothers and sister my brothers just
move forward I think we have enough
space there's people standing behind you
in the hallway if you can just scoot up
a little bit inshallah we'll have some
space what is this is a beautiful way
Allah has created for me and you to have
our sins forgiven by forgiven in a sense
that we act in the way of Allah subhana
tala and we build the the institutions
and the Charities around us and we
benefit that first and foremost I was
just informed before the Salah that this
year for some reason the Zak has not
even reached the halfway point so I
remind you it is absolutely obligatory
according
toat everybody in the household even if
they are a slave has to pay
zakat it is $12 per person and Zak
exists so my my and your Sam can be
purified for whatever shortcomings we've
had and we all know there are
shortcomings in this
month second of
all inshallah after Salat today you will
hear a call for building in addition to
the school so we can further benefit our
kids in the
community my brothers and sisters this
is a great cause you are protecting the
kids first and foremost by giving them
the teachings
of of
the and you're providing an Avenue for
us to Build a Better Community
tomorrow often a times we ask why do not
we have this and that well there's your
chance right here to invest into a
future to have a community that is
beneficial
for
sustainable Muslim
Students I can guarantee you myself
there's not a single student that's ever
turned away we always find a way to work
with them so inshallah there'll be a
call for that but realizing that this
could be a way for experation of our
sins doing the charity
work and keep in mind often a times when
I say charity work we have this idea
that I should be donating 60 80,000 a
million dollar 500,000 50,000 5,000
10,000 whatever I remind you of
theam and inshallah we'll finish with
this
today said do charity even if it's two
dates what is the cost of two
dates so inshallah we need to have the
mindset we ask Allah subhana to make
today the blessed day and a way out of
her Hellfire for all of us in the Muslim
we ask Allah subhana tala to relieve
the pain and suffering of our Muslim
brothers and sisters around the world in
China in BMA in
Kashmir in Iraq in Syria in Libya and
especially in festin andaza and in Sudan
may Allah subhana tala provide them food
from his
own places that we do not know exist and
Allah subh provide them the peace and
tranquility from his own sources may
Allah subh provide help to those from
the avenues that we do not see ya Allah
we ask you those who have corrupted have
done wrong Muslims especially until
today and time to come you do not let
them die until they see punishment in
this world and Grant them the Hellfire
in the afterwards and do not cut them
any concessions Ya Allah because when
they had Authority in this world they
not concessions to people they starve
them they didn't give them water they
didn't let them have Medical Aid they
kill children women merciless Ya Allah
kill them as they have killed the
Muslims in this
[Silence]
world
for
[Silence]
Allah
allahar
[Silence]
allar
strain your lines full the gaps in
between may Allah have mercy upon us if
you have mobile devices please switch
them off if you have young kids with
with you just keep them with you
[Silence]
inshd
amen
[Silence]
bah
allahar Sam
[Silence]
allahar
alhamd
[Silence]
amen
allahar
[Silence]
for
brothers and sisters asalamu
alaykum please please remain seated give
us few minutes of your time that's a
sodaka of your time so this is a blessed
day inshallah you'll benefit from it
independent of what we do but inshallah
it's a great blessing that to be with
you this evening or this afternoon and
as she Hassan already explained that we
are looking for expansion for the school
we are looking at four classrooms that
will be adding and inshallah the
construction the permits have been
granted already
I just want to thank and acknowledge
brother vam and his family to help us in
getting this the the permits in place
already so inshallah without any delay
we to ask who is going to pledge
the
$225,000
25,000 brothers and sisters anybody want
to pledge
25,000 I want to
pledge
from my
family how about
10,000
one 10
one another 10 please brothers and
sisters brothers look at this thing here
as a Saka jaria that will be there long
time after we leave this this world and
definitely it's a payment plan possible
available there's you don't have to pay
everything up front it could be up over
12 months or any amount of time that you
think you need to take care of that
pledge how about another 10,000 I want
to ask one more time and then we can
move on to how about
5,000 Dr Ran brother Nadim t
another
five
brother need another
five if you cannot if I cannot see you
you can stand up and make that pledge or
we can do privately or we can do
privately another five please brothers
and sisters I know the time is running
away from us and i' to ask one more
if we
can okay how about 25
$500 $2500 that's only $200 a month
spread over a year right
$2500 Dr Iman
Iman another one 2500 that's only
$200 a
month somebody else want to pledge
that brother just again reminder this is
a sadaka jaria is going to be for the
benefit of the youth in the future and
it is something that will be truly
rewarding
every